[beep]
both: OH, HELLO.
- OF COURSE,
I'M GIL FAIZON.
- AND I'M GEORGE ST. GEEGLAND.
- AND THIS IS OUR PRANK SHOW,
TOO MUCH TUNA.
- EACH WEEK WE PRANK A GUEST
BY GIVING THEM
TOO MUCH TUNA FISH.
- TODAY OUR GUEST
IS MY BEAUTIFUL STEPSON,
ELON FAIZON.
SO WHAT'S THE DEAL, ELON?
YOU SEXUALLY ACTIVE?
- UM, YEAH, YEAH.
[stammers] I'VE HAD SEX.
- LOOK, IF YOU EVER GET A GIRL
IN TROUBLE, YOU KNOW,
AND YOU NEED
TO GET HER OUT OF TROUBLE,
WE KNOW A GUY.
- DR. WONG.
HE'S A BACK-ALLEY GUY.
THE BUZZER SAYS
"PARTY PLANNERS U.S.A.,"
BUT IT'S A FRONT
FOR AN ABORTION CLINIC.
- HE'S PRETTY THOROUGH THOUGH.
- HE'S PRETTY THOROUGH.
YOU MUST BE HUNGRY.
HERE IT COMES.
- LOOK AT THIS BIG MOUNTAIN
OF TUNA FISH.
- YEAH,
THAT'S A LOT OF TUNA.
- WHAT'S THE MEANING
OF THIS?
- THIS IS PROBABLY
TOO MUCH TUNA.
- I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED,
ACTUALLY.
- TOO MUCH TUNA.
POW.
- NO, NO, I GET THAT.
IT'S A LOT OF TUNA.
IT'S JUST--
- THAT PLATE WAS DELIVERED WITH
ENTIRELY TOO MUCH TUNA FISH.
- YOU ASKED ME TO COME UPTOWN
TO EAT LUNCH WITH YOU.
- THIS IS LIKE THAT
ASHRAM KITCHEN SHOW, PUNK'D.
- OR WILMA VAMERRAMI'S
BLOW MOMMA.
- YEAH?
- THAT'S IT.
- DON'T, DON'T, DON'T--
- NO, IT'S SET
TO THE LIGHTING.
IT'S SET TO THE LIGHTING.
- I SEE THAT THERE'S LIGHTS.
THERE'S CAMERAS.
- NO, I POINT OUT
THE CAMERA.
THERE'S A CAMERA THERE.
- LET ME DO THIS ONE.
AND THEN THERE'S A CAMERA HERE.
- THERE'S A CREW.
CAN YOU GET THE CREW?
THERE'S A CREW OF PEOPLE
THAT WALKED INTO THIS ROOM.
- THESE ARE PEOPLE
AT THE RESTAURANT.
YOU DON'T KNOW YET
THAT IT'S A PRANK.
DOES HE KNOW?
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE PRANK,
YOU LITTLE [bleep]?